the Joe Rogan experience I went to a
wolf sanctuary this past weekend today
I'm white Friday yeah Friday yeah yeah
they are abused well but being
rehabilitated or something no no they're
not abused but they're they're contained
and that's what's depressing it's like
most of them came from people wanting a
wolf from a pet a pet they're like oh
I'm gonna have a wolf won't be about us
and then just rips your house apart and
doesn't listen to you at all oh my god
this isn't a dog yeah so big yeah
but to me what was depressing was first
of all they neuter them when they get in
there they kind of have to because they
don't want to breed because they didn't
create more of the same situation but
then the other thing is that they're in
this pen and then they don't get to be
free so there's not like a big the the
pen they were in it's not as big as a
studio it's not that big for a [ __ ]
wolf yeah we Wolf's want a run and hunt
that's what they want to do they want to
hunt study never rereleased them into
the Wow no I mean that's listen to this
though listen know how that's when we're
leaving we're leaving there a howl then
pens see how little the Pens are though
yeah we went into the pens and pet them
look these people they're amazing and
they're doing an amazing job don't get
me wrong
yeah I mean they're keeping these
animals alive and they're feeding them
and they do love them and they go in
there and and take care of them and pet
them but to me it's like that's a
[ __ ] wolf that wolf should be on a
mountain somewhere it should be chasing
down a deer it shouldn't be living like
that I don't they're beautiful it's just
I did just bummed me out yeah made me
feel like I went to a prison yeah you
know like these are incredible animals
and they're the only way they can keep
them is to that's a forest gallant who's
a wildlife biologist who's been on the
podcast for I'm getting kissed right
there by a wolf they're very sweet
like you can some of them you get pat
and hug them and hang on to them and
they like you you like people but
they're [ __ ] wolves like your you're
not telling them [ __ ] like there's no
sit lie down [ __ ] you like they're
wolves that's good that they have
somewhere to I can still rescue them
like yes people who would have just like
put him down and that is a lot of what
they did they did keep a lot of them
from being put down but but I left there
feeling really depressed how that figure
out what his name is but he has a huge
Instagram and he has like all the big
cats oh yeah what is anything called
yeah I can't think of it but it's like
something cat something Ming yet
probably doesn't even say that but
that's what I'm like big cat videos but
yeah the guy goes and he like cuddles
woman and it's always like someone who
had a pet tiger who was like just gonna
be cool no it wasn't mostly people in
Texas
yeah there's more tigers in captivity in
Texas in people's backyards and there
are in all the wild of the world that of
what and they are they're like no laws
with like animals doesn't give a [ __ ]
you won't draft go get yourself a
giraffe oh my god you just have a tiger
that might be fine I feel like it would
be more chill like staying and like I so
choose yeah they're so true I used to
have a bit about them like they're the
only animals that don't feel bad for at
the zoo because they're walking around
the zoo like another day with no Lions
Lions majestic that's a random account
oh no it's called black yeah yeah that's
right yeah it's a lot like that black
Jaguar something it's not I'm not sure
where it is but yeah yeah that's it
Jaguar white tiger yeah he's just
coddling Tigers [ __ ] he's in Mexico we
rested and I was born sold in Mexico
from horrible circumstances the most
depressing shy I ever saw for sure was a
tiger sanctuary in Thailand
it was so depressing because they were
all drugged because you take a picture
with a tiger
the Tigers landing like this like yeah
like just like a drug prostitute in a
room yeah
and people like smile and taking
pictures I know I said I am NOT going in
that [ __ ] cage and I'm not taking
part like wewe thought it was just a
tiger sanctuary rescue Tigers you go
look at Tigers I'm like be cool for my
kids to see some Tigers but then we got
there I'm like oh no these people are
getting and there's a difference because
like they have little Cubs and so you go
in a room there's a pen and these little
Cubs at tiny they're like a couple of
weeks old or you know four or five weeks
old whatever it is they could be around
people six weeks old and you could play
with them but they're super energetic
jumping on you and they're swatting
things are playing with each other and
rolling around and then as they get
older it gets to a year or two and then
they stop they stop being natural then
they are all drugged so you could be
around the littler Tigers and there's a
bunch of handlers around and everybody's
real nervous they keep the Tigers away
from you and the Tigers are there
looking at you but they're there they're
there kind of yeah but there are like a
year old then you get to the full-grown
Tigers and they just [ __ ] up they're
all drugged they're all drugged that's
crazy
that's like my brain never thought of
like oh yeah they must be drugged in
order to be sitting in a room with
strangers and not freaking out yeah that
makes so much sense if you go into that
room and the cage rather and see the
Tigers you know right away that yeah
yeah yeah that's a nice thing with that
black Jaguar Tiger guy like you always
see the Tigers I like playing with them
they're like swatting them around like
the kittens you're talking about and
like you can see like their claws I like
retracted so like they actually like the
guy they get just fun yeah they could
tear him apart at any point but they're
still like nibbling on him and stuff is
this like that guy's crazy he's like
like the big cat Steve Irwin I guess
yeah he's nuts there's a few of those
guys there's a guy in Texas that does
not get it
but he's got a tiger rehabilitation
place it's the same kind of deal like
wrestles with these Tigers employees
with them [ __ ] is not gonna end well bro
did you watch Siegfried and Roy yeah
yeah a lot of times they just decide to
go tiger on you and then it's like yeah
yeah put things yeah the wolf thing was
a real bummer I didn't think I was gonna
bum me out as much but it bummed me out
I mean I'm happy that those people are
doing it and then I think what they're
doing is amazing don't get me wrong but
for me like just a feeling of the like
being around that thing like other thing
wants to run
[Applause]